شهد شهر شباط فبراير الماضي حشدا عسكريا
روسيا على الحدود الاوكرانيه تبعه اعتراف
موسكو باستقلال
اوكرانيا
دون اي تاخير او ابطاء يجب الاعتراف
بجمهوريتيسك
في الرابع والعشرين من الشهر ذاته اقتحمت
جيش الروسي اراضي اوكرانيا من عده جهات
حتى وصل الى تخوم العاصمه كييف متقدما من
جنوب البلاد وشرقها وباسطا نفوذه على
اجزاء كبيره من المقاطعات مثل خرسون
وزابروجين واضعا اكبر محطه نوويه في
اوروبا تحت رقابه روسيا مطلع مارس ادار
الماضي
شهر نيسان ابريل شهد انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من مناطق اوكرانيه عديده بعد
تكبدها خسائر كبيره امام الجيش الاوكراني
في مدينه شرنج وبوتشا اطراف المدينه ما
زالت خطره حيث ان جيش الاوكراني ما زال
يكمن في الخنادق القريبه من هذه المناطق
اما الشرق الاوكراني فقد هاجمت فيه القوات
المواليه لروسيا مدنا في اطراف الاقاليم
وسيطر الانفصاليون على مدينه فالنظافه
واكملوا طريقهم الى مريوبل واستظروف
انسانيه صعبه ومعارك داميه في اواخر ما
يغير ذلك قبل ان يبسط الجيش الروسي نفوذه
على ضواحي مدينه خاركب حول مصنع ازوفيستال
والمحاصرين من المصابين ومن المقاتلين على
حد سواء اكمل مقاتلوا قدير سيطر تهم على
لوغانسك بعد انسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه من
معاقلها في مدينتي
تموز الماضي مدينه سيفرسك هي المدينه التي
انسحب اليها الجيش الاوكراني وخلفنا هنا
افراد من القوات الروسيه شهد شهر سبتمبر
ايلول امدادات عسكريه اوكرانيه دفعت الروس
للانسحاب من ضواحي خاركيف في اكتوبر تشرين
الاول تبعه انسحاب اخر من مدينه خرسون في
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني من العام ذاته
لتعود موسكو مطلع هذا العام وتدعم الجبهات
الشرقيه في دمباس بمزيد من المقاتلين
والاليات المتطوره وتدفع الجيش الاوكراني
للانسحاب تدريجيا من اراضي دمباس لقناتي
العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
[موسيقى]